I was in Louisville recently doing a  little show there drove up here  shut the [ __ ] up  [Applause]  who the [ __ ] is that proud about  Lewisville  who gives the [ __ ]  it's whoa  and how do you say it oh  but you're gonna say that because you're  just having his balls in your mind  oh but that's your son  hell yeah  way to go  [Applause]  the whole new meaning of the word Mill  I guess the glass is around the family  coming all over those dude  [Music]  [Applause]  um  well thank you  yeah  so I'm here from Louisville  [Applause]  I actually don't have an ax I'm just  gonna  it's gonna make fun of this couple over  here  God damn there's a mom  I would totally [ __ ] your mom  you don't let me  um  I want to do that  the bylaws with comedy prohibit that  kind of behavior  just kidding they allowed Cosby I think  I'm good today  [Applause]  but uh yeah I drove here from Kentucky  and  [Music]  [Applause]